So the democratic party to me,
and this is one of the things that it's fascinating about your story.
So you are one of the most prominent progressives in the state of Kentucky. Uh,
you've identified the real issues that people care about.
People will listen to you because they sense that you're a different voice
and the Democrats not being complete morons. We're like, Hey,
we should try and recruit him. Like, wait,
we should recruit this guy to run for office.
And you get asked about it every single cycle, which makes sense,
because you would be one of the most successful prospects that they could
possibly field. And you went so far as to attend, uh, uh,
one of those congressional candidate, uh, training camps. Um,
and after you went through that, you said, you know what,
I'm not sure I'm going to run, run that cycle. I think it was 16, uh,
when they were talking to you. Uh,
so tell us about why you took a hard look
and what your experience was.
Well, so I do a radio show every day and I would argue,
I am probably one of the only people in the country who is a progressive and an
outspoken progressive that speaks to a conservative audience every day,
70% of 75% of my audience are Trump voters.
And that's because that's the sports audience in Kentucky and they know I'm a
progressive, but they're okay with me because they think,
I think they think my heart is in the right place. So in 2016,
they called me up to consider running against Andy BARR in the congressional
district that represents Lexington, Kentucky, and long story short.
They asked me to come to this congressional boot camp where they teach people
how to run.
And I went there and I was with the 50 to 60 candidates that were in the swing
districts that you had to win the sort of purple districts.
And it included a lot of names of people that you would know.
And they basically did a three-day camp on how you win.
And it was the most depressing thing I have ever been a part of because my
theory, my thought was, okay, they're going to teach you how to campaign,
how to talk about issues. They're going to talk about, you know, what would you,
what's a good policy to have on this or that? None of that was a conversation.
No one Andrew even asked me what I believed on anything ever.
I mean, they just thought, well, you could win. So you should come and run.
I could have believed any, anything in the world and they wouldn't have known,
they didn't care. They just thought I could win. And at the bootcamp,
all they taught you, literally all they taught you was how to raise money.
The whole thing was about money.
A very prominent congressperson stood up and said, let me tell you what,
doesn't matter. Meeting with voters, doesn't matter. Your policies don't matter.
What matters,
what matters is how much money can you raise and how do you utilize it?
And when I heard her say that I knew I wasn't gonna run. Cause I was like,
I'm not going to do this.
This is such a terrible part of potentially being in office.
And in Congress, especially in the house,
you have such little power that they just see you as a number to get to a
majority. And I came home and I almost said,
you know what I'm done with politics, period. It was that depressing.
Now I didn't do that, but it really showed me.
And I'm sure the Republicans have the same thing.
It really showed me that at least at that level, it's not about issues.
It's not about anything except raising money and getting the vote to get the
majority. I'm the numbers guy.
Mad. And they probably told you this at the bootcamp. Um,
but the average successful congressional candidate raises and spends
$1.6 million, uh, on their campaign.
So you have to ask yourself, okay,
who the heck can raise $1.6 million for a congressional campaign.
But that's the reason they think the way they do. They're just like, well,
let's say you're a great human being. You have great vision. Uh, you know,
people really connect with you, but can you get $1.6 million? Uh,
and if not, then none of your personal qualities will care. They,
they become very, uh, very mechanical.
So, I mean, do you believe that? Cause I don't. Do you believe that?
Do I believe.
Leave that,
that the average congressional candidate candidate that's exceeds raises 1.6
billion?
Let's let's talk about what happened here in Kentucky during the Senate primary,
I got named Charles Booker, who I endorsed and really liked a lot,
nearly pulled off one of the most shocking primary upsets ever against Amy
McGrath,
Amy McGrath raised she's raised like $50 million for the Senate campaign.
At one point,
Charles Booker had like $30 in the bank and Booker got the
spark, mostly via social media.
And the money came after and I'm sort of, of the belief.
Now you need a base money or at least a base presence or a social media,
something, but the money for Charles he would have had,
if he had gotten the nomination,
he'd had all the money he needed against Mitch McConnell. Anybody. Heck yes.
Yeah, but he basically just,
once he got the spark and people knew who he was, he raised a lot of money.
And if he had had one more week left in the election,
he would have been the nominee and done very well.
I think against McConnell may not have beaten him, but he'd been closed.
I don't agree that it should be about who can have the most money.
Because I think Steve Bannon, who I think is a contempt contemptible person,
but he said, one thing I think is right,
which is actually think arguing art weirdly money almost matters less now
because there are so many ways to get it. And when you get to big races,
you'll get it anyway because people will want you to win.
So I don't know that I totally agree with that,
that like you gotta have that 1.6 million or why even do it.
I agree with your disagreeing. Uh, and Charles is a great example.
Candidates matter, candidates matter a great deal. You know, it's, it's,
it's one of the things that, uh, prompted me to run was I thought,
you know what? Like, I,
I think that this message needs to get out there and I think people will with it
and I believe I'll get the resources I need.
And I could've lived with myself if I hadn't, you know what I mean? It's not,
it's not like you could look at it and say, you can't know.
That's one of the things about these races too.
And you hit the nail on the head with Charles. Like,
like if Charles puts himself out there,
then he has a chance to get the resources he needs. You know, it's like,
can you know that someone ahead of time is going to get the resources? Sure.
In some cases, if they're just sitting on a giant pile of money, uh,
but the vast majority of candidates are going to have to put themselves out
there and hope that they catch that spark.
And then when they do catch that spark, then magical things can happen.
And those are the things that make the DC establishment, uh,
look up and be like, Oh, I did not see that coming. Um,
what's happening in the Senate race too. And I'd love to hear what your take is.
Uh, so Amy McGrath,
I believe had tens of millions of dollars for the primary.
She was already spending money on TV ads and the rest of it.
No one expected Charles to, um, challenge her seriously.
And then it became very serious where he almost took the, uh,
nomination and she squeaked it out. And then now Charles,
and everyone's behind her because you got to try and beat Mitch. Um,
but it seems like she is not as close as you'd hope. Uh,
last thing I saw, I had her down like nine or 10 points.
So why is it that people in Kentucky are not excited about Amy and I, you know,
I don't want to put words in anyone's mouth, but you know, like,
I don't know if you agree with the fact that people aren't excited. I mean.
I don't want to be negative towards Amy because I think she is a good person,
but I she's going to lose by 20.
I really believe that 15 to 20 in Mitch,
please I wrote about, I actually was thinking about that race seriously.
I mean, not just kind of thinking about it. I went into it, I did polling.
I put my own personal money into looking at it and I detailed
pretty, you know,
specifically how it is that candidates end up not running.
And this is no offense to Amy McGrath, but my race is an example.
So I was considering running and Chuck Schumer and the DSCC decided Amy
McGrath is going to be our candidate.
And what that was meaning was I could not even get people,
Andrew to work for me. There are nine polling, uh,
democratic polling sources.
And none of them would take me because the DSCC told them, if you work for him,
you can't work for any of our candidates.
I couldn't find anyone to even help me.
The only people that would help me were these sort of rogue progressives who
were very nice,
but also didn't want me to tell anybody they were working for me because they
were worried that Schumer and those people would get mad at him.
Schumer basically put a, if you help him and not, when I say Schumer,
it was the DSCC. As he see specifically, if you work for him,
you can't do anything for us.
So there was a major democratic party donor here in Kentucky.
And one of the biggest national donors who lied,
who thought I was the best candidate and basically went to Schumer and said,
look, you got to give this guy a chance. And only because of that,
did he agree to meet with me?
And I've talked specifically about what happened in that meeting.
It was a fine meeting. He brought me up, I spent a couple hours with him.
He agreed to finally like take his hand off the button and let me recruit
people. But he told me flat out,
I don't think anybody can beat Mitch McConnell were for Amy McGrath.
Cause we know she can raise money and it will keep Mitch distracted.
That's he told me that flat out and I said, I think you're wrong.
Someone can beat him. And he said, well, if you want to try and go for it.
But their whole thing was just to get someone who could raise money.
And they knew that Amy McGrath was a money raising machine.
They just gave up on Kentucky before it even started. And it was infuriating.
I ended up not doing it, but I'd have to tell you, Andrew,
I almost did it just to, just to prove them wrong, you know,
but Charles is a perfect example,
Charles and there's polling private polling that suggests this Charles would
have made this a much closer race,
but Chuck Schumer didn't care about it being a close race.
He cared about the money being raised. And that's the problem.
That is very tough to hear because there are so many missed
opportunities, really, uh, Amy's background.
Um,
I mean she obviously is a very impressive personal and a military background.
Then she'd raised a ton of money in an earlier race. Um, so what were those,
the reasons why Chuck looked up or the DSCC looked up and said, okay, um,
we're going to get behind Amy because she'd like,
how much did you raise in our previous race?
Well, on paper, she's a perfect candidate, military veteran,
very smart, engaging, et cetera. But races are not run on paper.
She raised a lot of money in 2018 in a midterm partially
because she put out one of the best television commercials you'll ever see,
which was her first commercial, which went viral and she raised a ton of money,
but I think this is important. She lost.
And she lost when the polls said that she was going to win,
she way underperformed expectations, but it was like nobody even cared.
They just sort of moved past that and said, well, you know,
still she's the best candidate.
I think what you get is when you have people from Washington DC
saying what they believe people in Kentucky will like,
they're going to screw it up. I mean, what do they know?
They're not in Kentucky. If you had been here in 2018.
And I say this with no offense to Amy McGrath, who I think is, you know,
a good person and, and, and uh, military hero.
But if you had been here in 2018,
you would know that she could not beat Mitch McConnell.
And that putting her in the race in Kentucky was a terrible mistake.
You would just know that,
but I don't think anybody in Kentucky was ever even consulted the question
just who did, who did Chuck Schumer want? And when Chuck Schumer wanted them,
they win.
And I think there are other examples around the country that it is very
difficult in a primary to beat the establishment pick. So,
and then the field gets weighted because she raised so much money.
She raised like $8 million her first two weeks in the campaign, Andrew,
how am I supposed to compete in a primary against somebody has $8 million when
we're, and then when they tell big donors, don't give him money.
Where am I supposed to get any money? No, Charles Booker,
if it was not for the black lives matter protest,
he may have never even gotten sort of noticed,
but he did because he was such a great leader during that time period.
But before that, she just had so much money. It was impossible.
And that was all done by the national party. And this is a missed opportunity.
I'm not gonna lie. It would have been hard to beat.
Mitch McConnell would not have been easy.
You would have had to run a perfect race, especially with Trump on the ballot.
If he wasn't on the ballot, it's different.
But it was possible. Thank you for listening in.
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.